John Kramer is back with a brand-new set of
death traps and nefarious intentions, so here's
everything you need to know before watching
"Saw X".
Horror movies aren't just reserved for the
spooky season, with freaky films popping up
all-year round.
But there is something about a horror flick
being released around Halloween that gives
it a particularly special feel.
Luckily for gore hounds, "Saw X" will start
the scary celebration with a blood-soaked
bang, as it's hitting theaters on September
29, 2023.
Interestingly, "Saw X" finds itself sandwiched
between quite a few noteworthy horror titles.
It'll be following in the wake of "The Nun
2," but it's coming out before other creepy
flicks such as "The Exorcist: Believer" and
"Five Nights at Freddy's."
Basically, Halloween Season 2023 is going
to be an absolute treat for anyone wanting
to celebrate at the theater, and "Saw X" is
sure to deliver the goods when it kicks off
the frightful festivities.
We know the film is actually going to be something
of a prequel -- taking place after the original
"Saw" movie but before the events of "Saw
2."
That means we'll be following John Kramer
during his final days, battling cancer and
searching for some sort of miracle cure.
John's desperation will take him to Mexico,
where he's hoping to sign up for an experimental
medical procedure.
Unfortunately, John finds out that there's
no actual cure.
The people making lofty promises are all con
artists, and there's no hope for John's health
below the border.
Of course, now that the Jigsaw Killer has
traveled all this way, he isn't going to waste
the opportunity to murder some people, now
is he?
Furious at the scammers for taking advantage
of hopeless people, John decides it's time
to play a game.
Soon enough, the folks who lured John to Mexico
with promises of salvation will find themselves
trapped in a hell of Jigsaw's making and punished
for their sins.
"Let the game begin."
Going into "Saw X," fans of the series wanted
to know only one thing -- would Tobin Bell
reprise his role as John Kramer?
The good news is, Bell is indeed coming back.
Remarking on his return, the franchise producers
expressed excitement at Bell's return and
mentioned how the John Kramer character is
a major part of the franchise's success.
Director Kevin Greutert agreed with this sentiment,
telling Empire that "Saw X" would focus on
Jigsaw more than any other film in the series.
We'll also see quite a few new faces populating
the screen, with the talented cast including
the likes of Steven Brand, Michael Beach,
Renata Vaca, Paulette Hernandez, Joshua Okamoto,
Octavio Hinojosa, and Synnøve Macody Lund.
But will we see any former "Saw" stars returning
alongside Tobin Bell?
It's entirely possible.
Shawnee Smith is definitely returning as John
Kramer apprentice Amanda Young, and for a
while, there was a rumor that Cary Elwes could
return as serial killer Dr. Lawrence Gordon.
Unfortunately for fans, Elwes told Screen
Rant in April 2023:
"I have no comment one way or the other about
that franchise; I really can't speak to it.
I'm happy for the filmmakers that they continue
to make money, and that it seems to be a financial
bonus for them, I really can't speak to it
because I'm not really involved anymore."
Director Kevin Greutert is no stranger to
the "Saw" franchise, as he helmed 2009's "Saw
6" and 2010's "Saw 3D."
While those were his first two feature film
directorial pursuits, he followed them up
with three more horror thrillers -- "Jessabelle,"
"Visions," and "Jackals."
Of course, he isn't the only "Saw" alum working
behind the scenes.
Peter Goldfinger and Josh Stolberg have penned
the screenplay, and their credits include
both "Spiral" and "Jigsaw," proving they're
incredibly familiar with the nefarious games
and sadistic challenges of the "Saw" franchise.
To hear Greutert tell it, "Saw X" is going
to be his greatest contribution to the series yet.
Back in February 2023, when shooting wrapped
on the movie, Greutert gave fans an update
on the site formerly known as Twitter, saying:
"It was one of the most rewarding and epic
experiences of my life."
Greutert went on to say that he wanted to
use "Saw X" as the title for the new movie.
For diehard fans, Greutert promised the film
would get back to the core of the franchise
and focus on John Kramer.
Fans will have to decide for themselves if
"Saw X" lives up to Greutert's enthusiasm.
It might be hard to remember the last time
there was a new "Saw" movie because the last
time the franchise came to the big screen,
it delivered a spin-off story.
2021's "Spiral: From the Book of Saw" told
the story of Detective Zeke Banks searching
for a serial killer clearly inspired by Jigsaw.
Speaking to The AU Review, he said:
"This is not the ninth film in the Saw franchise.
There easily could be a Saw 9 that follows
Jigsaw."
"Saw X" seems to prove Bousman's remark completely
wrong.
It implies that "Spiral" was a "Saw" movie
and completely avoids picking up where "Jigsaw"
left off at the same time.
"Saw X" is jumping back in time all the way
to the early 2000s when John Kramer is still
alive and wreaking havoc, so it's safe to
say we won't be seeing Detective Banks in this outing.
It's disappointing since the twisty ending
of "Spiral" left fans with a serious cliffhanger.
Undoubtedly, there will be many fans wondering
what would have happened next in Detective
Banks' journey and if he would have finally
got revenge for what Emmerson did.
If that's the case, what was the point of
"Spiral" leaving things so open-ended in the
first place?
It seems likely that "Spiral" was meant to
kick off a new era for the "Saw" franchise.
Having "From the Book of Saw" in its title
clearly set "Spiral" apart from the rest of
the series and implied that there were more
stories like it to tell.
The plan might have been to expand on Detective
Banks's story and to look at more serial killers
inspired by Jigsaw's legacy.
That plan didn't work out because the numbers
didn't support it.
"Spiral" completely bombed at the box office
in its opening weekend, which definitely dumped
cold water on the potential for "Spiral 2."
Now that "Saw X" is taking the series back
to its roots, "The Book of Saw" might officially be closed.
"Wait, I thought the Jigsaw Killer was dead."
"Yeah, but if it's another copycat…"
"It's going to be a sh**show."
It might come as a surprise that "Saw X" is
traveling back in time to the early 2000s,
but it really shouldn't.
The horror genre is well-known for taking
the occasional odd left turn after a series
has been kicking around for a long time.
After we sent Jason to space, everything was
on the table.
Fans of this particular franchise should already
be used to chronological shenanigans.
For one thing, "Saw 3" and "Saw 4" happen
simultaneously and the viewer only realizes
it later.
Piecing together the entire "Saw" franchise
timeline involves more than just watching
the movies in order.
Many characters, including the all-important
John Kramer, have their backstories explained
in flashback sequences only after they've
hung around for several movies.
There's only one reason that "Saw X" is going
so far back in the timeline, and fans will
probably agree it's a good one.
John Kramer, the original Jigsaw, died all
the way back in "Saw 3."
Since then the franchise has included him
in flashbacks and prequel stories while mostly
following copycat killers.
"Saw X" is bringing the franchise back to
where it started by setting its story in the
past and letting John Kramer return to the
spotlight for real.
It may be good to know that "Saw X" is in
experienced hands, but regardless of who's
working on the movie behind the camera, fans
are showing up for the man who's on screen.
Tobin Bell helped bring Jigsaw to life in
the original "Saw," and he's been the core
of the franchise ever since.
Bell has been in every "Saw" movie except
for 2021's "Spiral," and he's clearly excited
to get a chance to return to the character.
In an interview with Build, Bell talked about
what has kept him so engaged with the character
for the past two decades.
"He's got huge dimension as a character.
He's a bit of a philosopher."
Bell added that he'd always be willing to
play a character that interested him as much
as Jigsaw.
He also talked about the potential for "Saw
X" to introduce the character to audiences
who were too young to see the original "Saw"
and its immediate sequels in theaters.
If there really is a huge influx of new fans,
"Saw X" will be just the beginning of a new
slate of "Saw" movies.
There are many words that could accurately
describe John Kramer, but "hero" definitely
isn't one of them.
As Jigsaw, John has killed more people than
anyone can count, and he's developed some
of the most gruesome ways to murder people
that the world has ever seen.
Despite that, "Saw X" does seem to be putting
John into the position of a typical horror
movie hero.
In the movie, John goes to Mexico City to
seek specialized treatment for his terminal cancer.
The people who treat him are scammers who
want to steal his money by convincing him
they're medical professionals.
When John realizes that he's been ripped off,
he sets about punishing the scammers with
his usual assortment of horrifying traps.
Whether or not that premise goes far enough
to justify John's brutal murders is up to
the fans, but "Saw X" goes out of its way
to make John the frontman of the movie.
Speaking about the film at a fan panel Midsummer
Scream 2023, producer Oren Koules said:
"John Kramer is absolutely the protagonist
in this movie."
The producer confirmed that what John experiences
makes him the hero of the film.
Maybe anti-hero would be a more accurate term,
but Koules's point is important.
Fans who have been dying to see more John
Kramer finally have a movie where he's the
real lead character.
2024 marks the 20th anniversary of the first
"Saw" movie.
Directed by James Wan, "Saw" caught the attention
of so many horror fans because of its no-holds-barred
approach to on-screen violence and its remarkable
twist ending.
The franchise has never exactly been a critical
darling, but it kept filling theaters, so
the series continued.
But "Saw" has seen better days.
We've come a long way since the yearly releases
of the late 2000s.
Nowadays, "Saw" movies are few and far between,
and they aren't guaranteed to be successes.
"Spiral" had such an abysmal box office performance
that some were wondering if it meant the franchise
was finally dead.
"Saw X" proves that there's still some room
for the series to keep going.
Clearly the people responsible for making
"Saw" movies still believe in them.
Tobin Bell is still excited by the characters,
and producers and directors are willing to
put time and money into making a new movie.
On the other hand, "Saw X" could end up being
a swan song for the series.
One way or another, the future of the entire
franchise rests on how well "Saw X" is received
when it finally debuts.
"Oh, yes.
There will be blood."
What's in a name?
"Saw X" might seem like an obvious title choice,
but there's actually a little bit of depth
to the name.
It seemingly confirms that "Spiral" was the
ninth "Saw" movie, regardless of what its
director had to say.
But this latest installment isn't taking a
cue from "Fast X" with its title either.
Instead, "Saw X" is borrowing a title formula
from the franchise's early days to make it
loud and clear that John Kramer has returned
and "Saw" is back in fighting form.
When "Saw" was just starting, every movie
in the series got a Roman numeral after the title.
That finally changed with 2010's "Saw 3D,"
which made an ill-fated attempt to bring "Saw"
into a new dimension.
Since then, "Jigsaw" and "Spiral" are the
only "Saw" movies we've gotten.
"Saw X" is calling back to the original films
with its title, and by placing its story right
back in the good old days of the franchise.
All the "Saw" movies end up in a grimy warehouse
at one point or another because that's where
Jigsaw sets up his traps.
The movies haven't ever spent much time exploring
the city beyond those warehouses.
Even "Spiral," which spent more time out in
the daylight than any other "Saw" movie, never
really clarified the setting.
For all the incredible attention to detail
that "Saw" pays to the intricate backstory
of its main character and the torturous traps
he invents, the movies never even tell us
where they take place.
Don't expect that to be the case with "Saw
X."
The trend of setting location-agnostic stories
is going out the window with the franchise's
latest installment.
In the movie, John heads to Mexico City in
search of cancer treatment, and the city is
going to play a huge role in the story.
"Saw X" was shot on location in Mexico City,
so we'll get to see all the sights alongside
John before the trap-making gets underway.
Taking John Kramer to Mexico pulls the franchise
out of the U.S. and into a specific location
for the very first time.
The change gives the movie a chance to tell
a new kind of story, and it thrilled the people
who were working on "Saw X."
Speaking to fans at Midsummer Scream 2023,
"Saw X" production designer Anthony Stabley said:
"For us from the get-go, we were already winning
because Mexico is so exotic, and John Kramer's
like a fish out of water."
Finally pushing John into a space where he's
not in control lets fans see the character
in a whole new light.
Also, it makes for a welcome change to the
usual locations where he lets his nefarious
imagination run wild.
Director Kevin Greutert knows exactly where
the "Saw" franchise has been before, and he
wanted to use Mexico City as fuel for telling
a story that "Saw" fans haven't already seen previously.
Speaking at Midsummer Scream 2023, he said:
"There's such a mythology, the city is so
amazing, and we can't speak enough about it.
And just that, there’s a certain creepiness
to it and a certain history, and it just absolutely
worked for us."
"It stood the test of time."
Coming in at one hour and 58 minutes, "Saw
X" is the longest film in the series to date.
Naturally, that means there will be enough
time to show off the real main attraction
of the movie and what everyone is here for:
The traps.
As with every new "Saw" movie, you can expect
"Saw X" to be filled with brand new, hyper-violent
contraptions.
The poster for the movie already gives a hint
of what to expect.
It shows someone locked into a set of creepy
goggles that have tubes connected to the eyes.
Whatever the device is meant to do, watching
it in action will probably make you cringe
and have sympathy pains.
The official "Saw X" trailer also gives a
few brief glances at John's inventions in the movie.
It shows a group of people chained up inside
a classic "Saw" warehouse.
One woman appears to have a saw blade set
up in front of her neck.
A panicked man is strapped into some kind
of modified electric chair.
In a different shot, we can see a Jigsaw puppet
wheeling out surgical supplies to John's victims.
From the little we've seen, "Saw X" looks
to be as gruesome as its predecessors.
Every time a series introduces a new prequel,
the chances for retconning skyrocket.
Altering a story's past is one of the best
ways to dramatically change its future.
On the surface, "Saw X" seems like a perfect
opportunity for the "Saw" canon to reinvent itself.
Maybe John Kramer had a secret child.
Or perhaps his time in Mexico City gave him
the perfect strategy for faking his death
at the end of "Saw 3," and he's been alive
all this time.
"Saw X" could hit the restart button for the
franchise in any number of ways, but it probably won't.
If the franchise really wanted to take things
in a different direction, it probably wouldn't
be diving back into John Kramer's past at
all.
John has been dead for the majority of the
franchise's existence at this point, so retconning
his death would completely ruin the story
of most of the movies.
Aside from John's death, there's really no
big event in the series that is even remotely
asking for a retcon.
It seems pretty safe to assume that "Saw X"
is going back in time just to give us another
Jigsaw story, and it probably won't do anything
that impacts what the rest of the series has
already established.
The latest installment's director, Kevin Greutert,
thinks that the franchise could continue,
but he's just not entirely sure how.
Speaking to SFX, he said:
"There's no obvious direction to go after
this film, but I think there probably will
be more Saw movies, particularly if this one
is successful."
"I'm long gone from this world."
Considering that the original "Saw" came out
in 2004, there's now an entire generation
of moviegoers who missed out on the franchise's
heyday.
"Saw" made enough of a cultural impact that
even people who were young enough to miss
actually seeing the movie probably knew a
little about its premise.
There's an extensive backlog of "Saw" movies
for new fans to brush up on, but it's probably
not necessary to see them all before showing
up at the theater for "Saw X."
Anyone who's looking for the bare minimum
catch-up story before "Saw X" should at least
watch the original movie.
It takes place right before the events of
"Saw X," but to really get the full context,
it's also worth watching "Saw 2" and "Saw
3," which carry the story through to the death
of John Kramer.
After that, watching "Saw 4" all the way through
to "Jigsaw" will give fans the fullest possible
picture of John's story and the lives of the
killers he inspired.
Beyond that, true completists can check out
"Spiral," if they haven't already.